ces huit d'or le chroniqueur tpm paix de
l'année
oui voici la liste des nominés c'est un
bon moment
dans la catégorie awards du chroniqueur
tpm paix de l'année les nommés sont
gilles verdez pour ses envolées lyriques
[Musique]
bernard montiel et ses punchlines julien
odoul est bon c'est pas grave je vous en
veux pas si vous êtes dans la défaite
c'est
guillaume genton pour ces fous rires la
répétition avec cyril
mélangés avec les autres
il a eu peur il a sauté sur le truc mais
tu ne peux pas vrai la mairie rémois
bout qui apparemment n'a pas trop aimé
nous du bain de rugby tu es perdu je
savais même pas qu'il y ait de
l'ambition
moi je te vois sur ton sur ton
physique
et matthieu delormeau pour son moonwalk
allongée toc toc toc qui est c'est manu
manu et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'aimerais qu'on revoit quand même bien
que j'entends
alors il faut comprendre qu'en fait
j'avais games qui étaient là moi j'étais
là et en fait c'est rim c'est plus
regardé la séquence est en fait se
retourner la voix chevrotante de boeuf
c'est parce qu'il avait jeté les gants
devant
les élus c'était hyper hyper fémur
htm alors ben moi aussi je sais d'où il
vient après aujourd'hui les american
staff en train de les mélanger les uns
avec les autres
c'est facile il a eu peur il a sauté sur
un truc mais tu ne peux pas vrai à la
mairie pour le fait que c'est un chien
qui ne risquez rien nicolas ça vous fait
marrer aulaqi qui n'encaisse à tafer ma
7e à rio comme cette ferrari
c'était séquence était sûr et c'est pour
vous le dis vive notre éditeur ce qui a
écouté je vous dire là mon coeur balance
vraiment entre dombes guillaume sur ce
moment raymond forcément et mathieu je
sais pas qui je pourrai pas me paraît
pas déçu ses fans et raymond laymond
parce que c'est tellement audacieux fin
il arrive tellement lui parler à la fin
si c'est incroyable ce qu'il dit parce
que je pense qu'il est tout ce qu on
s'est tous dit ces réseaux n'est fait
tout le temps oui ça deborah n'en parle
jeu mercredi 47 mamère séquences n'ont
globalement pouf pouf meilleurs
chroniqueurs c'est matthieu delormeau
pour moi c'est quelqu'un d'exceptionnel
arrange le trou extrêmement drôle tout
rappelle qu'elle fait tpp du doigt des
drones dessous des taux ils dansent
extrêmement bien il a un corps d'apollon
et je vous rappelle qu'il a lequel à 48
ans les goals et quand ils le disent et
alors ça veut dire quoi et je trouve
qu'ils ont les moyens en temps devant
lui voler comme une arbalète et n'avait
pas joué très bien et elle omet match à
côté de toi non les benjamins ses pattes
a fondu la magie
[Applaudissements]
à tout cela
un peu de respect pour l'animateur nom
de
gregory est un
fait extrêmement bon ben vous n'êtes pas
du tout le même jour là
il est vraiment beau les vous êtes
gaulle est vraiment
bon c'est vrai il ya moins de table est
un peu moins mais bon y'a plus il sert
mais le quasar actes donc ça très bien
plus de téton peut-être is merci de m on
va trop voir où va son mari gilles quand
même moi j'ai choisi nancy chronique
mais bon on sait plus du tout où bien
des transparents là rires le pen
american staff
r non je m'en fous je joue jamais je ne
pouvais plus mais le mode mission mais
moi le plus du tout mais je vous ai je
vous supplie de plus on regarde déjà
vers des
sucs au nigeria ayant suivi elle
connaît rien à rien
à l'auteur des centaines de victimes on
sait même pas pourquoi tu es là que
c'est
c'était moi
ce niveau que les twitter c'est ridicule
et détroit il te fait du val
une j'ai du mal
[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi
on va remettre le zénith d'or pour
gilles évidemment raymond mais je pense
que gilles et elle a été exceptionnelle
et raymond qui parle est arrivé c'est
vrai qu'il a une façon de parler il nous
a sauvé tous y at-il vraiment tout ce
qu'on pensait il l'a dit en une seule
phrase
ne pas rencontrer de malheur dans sa vie
mais tu es complètement paumé faut que
tu te retrouve le plus vite possible tu
peux pas arriver là et dire je t'envie
de vivait dans un hlm parce que tu es
perdu tu arrivais pas je veux
lamborghini roadies bemba dégénère il ya
des trucs intéressants c'est mon cul tu
es perdu je sais même pas que c est
l'ambition de ce qu'est ce que tu fous
les
mémoires regarde la musique moi je t'ai
bat axel foye sur ton service garde ton
physique meilleur
un truc est simple essaye de gagner ta
vie en mettant des glaces et entre les
tricheurs des cols roulés et là on mord
pas tu gagnes ta vie active
c'est le rennais alors on remet à qui
allez agile
allez passons maintenant aux
chroniqueurs pas ouf de l'année les
nommés sont
dans la catégorie au cours du
chroniqueur des pmp pas ouf de l'année
les nommés sont gilles verdez qui cinq
ans après sa demande en mariage à fatou
va peut-être enfin se marier on va lui
dire ce que tu m'as dit hier voilà tu
vas lui dira cyril il vat entendre qu
est ce que tu es parti faire
bernard montiel pour ses talents cachés
de comédien j'ai tourné dans une série
héricois c'est quoi le capitaine marleau
capitaine charles
guillaume genton pour ses nombreux
dérapages dont lé indique t'elle années
de sa grille mais l'armée
rémois boue qui a déjà gagné sa place
dans et bnp pour l'année prochaine à
manger à des femmes et ce par des
événements footballeur qui
est matthieu delormeau qui aimerait bien
jouer avec le maître de midi aux 12
coups de midi j'ai pas de mec jamais
tout seul du coup le lendemain c'est
refaire les seins
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
alors vous avez compris pour fatou
diallo on a pris les mêmes dans les
meilleurs et dans les pièges l'année
mais également à ses jours oui on est
gentils nous on est gentil alors vous
mais ramon tiennent à votre avis moi
j'aime bien le kenji là c'est drôle de
lons et ceux plus drôle je vous
ramènerai genre chroniqueur pas ouf
alors que c'est tellement drôle ça c'est
une punchline excès plaisir c'était
assez drôle très drôle et juste mérite
un oscar bébé merci
à guillaume single cd key mathieu
mathieu barrette et mathieu régime est
surtout
visible même mathieu pas c'est quelqu'un
de très drôle il vraiment
et oui venir sont
choisis bien avec ton père ou triangle
non moi pas les loups qu'ils se
reprochent à guillaume je trouve que tu
t'es perdu un peu cette année tu vas
commence à vouloir sortir avec delphine
wespiser après tu as voulu boudiaf
daniel entre temps sa durée même pas
deux mois et je trouve qu'il n'ya pas du
tout de rapport entre ces deux personnes
elle y fait son conseil de classe
animons amiens
c'est sûr que ça gueule j'aimerais bien
le savoir quoi madame vous faites là
quoi ici bas
[Rires]
merci beaucoup à vous écouter
au nom à nos boutons adaptés chroniqueur
je parlais avec vous madame c'était
ainsi quand est revu pour ckoi
rébus j'ai une comprend pas d'afflux
engage
pas facilement
savoir non alors moi ma révélation cette
année c'est guillaume a oui mais
vraiment parce que mathieu s'est
iconique match et ça y est c'est acté et
lui c'est sédhiou number one hal gill
est ce pareil ça fait des années ça y
est bernard c'est c'est une statue il
est là depuis les allées du commandeur
satuc en visite de moi je trouve que
vous vous prenez pour la statue de la
liberté on peut rentrer dedans
elles s'étaient toutes les williams
c'est vrai il a vraiment apporté quelque
chose et le différend je trouve qu'il
est ils avaient eu pour la maison drôle
et puis j'ai apprécié tout plane et
merci tous les maux débile que tu m'as
fait placé mercredi donc je tiens à dire
dans tout le monde aujourd'hui que si
des fois je disais l'économie c'est de
sa faute c'est bon
[Applaudissements]
jean tendance est à
nice 2 1 non mais la
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
radio et anissa excuses à ses livres
désolé
vous avez pris sur les réseaux al
issaoui a également était un peu vexé
alors vous parlez de mathieu le petit
mathieu série match rihaoui l'icône on
l'est l'apollon tellement beau match ça
suffit maintenant on va revoir les
images de mathieu et jacques mathieu
c'est quand même le mec qui drague plus
de personnes différentes années c'est
vrai il alors c'est parce qu'il a
beaucoup de conquêtes mais en tous les
cas il fait beaucoup de encore en cours
de rencontre est aussi récolter entre la
rencontre la conquête pour placer la
montre kate
[Musique]
j'ai pas de mec jamais tout seul du coup
le lendemain c'est refaire les seins
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
bah
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
je ne te cache pas bruno que tu sortes
beaucoup de cash
la bonne étoile mystérieuse
sincèrement
je trouve que c'est un très bon comédien
mathieu on peut dire qu il voulait très
fort pour que personne ne l'appelle
c'est vrai mais s'ils enlèvent bah oui
il a rejoint carrément il avait dit à
christian clavier qui était notre humble
avis un gastambide agace tant qu'ils
incarnaient il fait ses deux filles avec
son téléphone
alors on va on va créer une catégorie
maintenant tu sais la catégorie du plus
gros susurre du plateau
derrière du monde y appelle des
spécimens on va voir on va revoir le
[ __ ] en chef de l'année c'est vraiment
bien sûr mais la bastide mais je pense
qu'il a agi au nom raymond et on va
trouver à
partir du moment où tu es producteur
d'une boîte petit signe de 150 ch est
que ce sont 57 à plein tube à manger à
des familles cela partait émission
ramène-moi footballeur
attention
[Applaudissements]
matters des conditions toujours ça vous
êtes des cas
c'est un second temps j'ai beaucoup
concentrés là c'est génial voulais
qu'ils recommencent
[Applaudissements]
j'ai beau ça m'a joué un peu gilles
verdez crm on vient vous êtes hors
catégorie